this is a production of cornell
university
my name is brian ellis i
am the section leader for the climate
forestry and carbon section in the
division of lamp and forest the new york
state dec so that's quite a mouthful
but today what i'm going to try to talk
to everyone about is
um
the new york state stats and trends of
our forest so we learned a lot about
carbon stock versus carbon sequestration
today
some things that affect it and i'm going
to talk about
the challenge that we have ahead
in terms of where new york forests are
so the status of those forests and then
i'm going to talk about some policy
issues talk about
the climate leadership and community
protection act the clcpa and the
forestry recommendations that we've made
there to help us meet our climate goals
by 2050
and a brief overview of of those main
strategies that we've we've identified
for combating climate change through
through forests
is keeping forests as forests and that's
avoiding conversion of our forests to
non-forested use
improved forest management within our
current forested areas
aforestation and reforestation
urban forestry for trees in our urban
areas which
have multiple benefits in terms of
carbon sequestration but also
cooling effects in those urban heat
islands
reducing energy costs for in those areas
and then i'm going to touch briefly on
bioeconomy but tim went over that really
well
and the benefits of it and you know
that's something that
uh the recommendations in the four feet
panel
outlay that need to be pushed further
and we need to really incentivize um
getting more of that on the landscape
and then i'm going to talk about some
current dec programs opportunities for
landowners um you know if we have
landowners out on the call here um that
dec has
um what you can do on your properties
um and obviously
uh this is work that dec has been doing
for a while um but hasn't um
had as much of a climate lens on it and
it also you know is something that's
going to need to be ramped up if we're
really going to
make an impact moving forward
so just a brief overview of the the
clcpa
it establi it was passed um a few years
ago an established climate action
council
to
which was made to develop a scoping plan
which is basically a plan of action for
us to meet our climate goals in new york
and those goals are
70
renewable energy by 2030 100 percent
zero emissions from electrical
generation by 2040 and 85 reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions uh by 2050 with
the the goal of net zero emissions in
new york by 2050 and so if you look at
those that 85 reduction in greenhouse
gas emissions um getting to that 100
percent the last 15 of that would be
from carbon sequestration within our
forests
and so that's you know where we're going
is looking at the carbon sequestration
rates of new york's forest working on
increasing that and and offsetting about
um 15
of
our emissions in new york uh with
with sequestration from our forests
so a brief overview of of our forests in
new york and tim tim talked about the
trends of forests in new york a little
bit um
and i think it was really important for
us to think about the the loss of
forests in new york um from the 18th
century into the 19th century um
and you know the the steady incline in
force that we've had as
forests have regrown on agricultural
lands and that's a really important
context to
think about when we're talking about
forests in new york so we have about
18.6 million acres of forest in new york
currently and that's about 16
or 62 percent of new york forest
and when i'm talking about these four
stats which i'm going to talk about for
the next couple slides here most of the
information that i'm talking about comes
from the forest inventory analysis
program or fia program and that's run by
the forest service it's permanent plots
across new york landscapes that
it monitors new york forests and we get
annual reports from those as well as
five year reports which are much more in
depth so the most recent one was
published in 2020
and that's where most of the data that
i'll be talking about in that comes from
but um so the the most concerning part
of this trend and as we you know it's
really great to think of new york forest
regrowing we've had increase in forest
area for over 50 years in new york state
um in close to 100 years now
and but in the last 10 years we've been
losing forests in new york um so since
about 2012 we've had a decrease of about
one percent of forest area
um and we're seeing when you look at you
break down that force loss we're seeing
that about 49 of it is from agriculture
and about 33 of it is from development
so you know this kind of tells us
that
we've kind of gained a lot of that force
that we we would gain naturally from
people abandoning agricultural fields
we're starting to see you know some
farmers take back those areas um and
then we're also seeing you know lots of
developments sprawl into our forested
areas and and affect those
those forested areas and i think um
as we look at the status of new york
forests and the gains and losses over
the years we'll typically see a flux
between agriculture and forests
every every year or you know every five
year cycle that we get these more
in-depth reports and so that's less
concerning because those areas are
natural areas that will be able to
regrow over time
the loss to development is definitely a
more concerning loss in that you know
those areas are definitely harder for
forests to reclaim or more permanent
loss and
um as tim laid out those are definitely
a big carbon uh release when we when we
talk about
loss to development
and so the next thing that i think is
important to discuss
when talking about these goals and
um
and the forest of new york is to
understand where our forests are in new
york um who owns our forest so we can
can think about it how to effect
management across the forests in new
york so um as many people here know
about 3.1 million acres of forest area
in new york is in the adirondack and
catskill park as well as you know uh
state parks and so those are areas that
are not managed they're
gaining
carbon stocks over time but you know as
they regrow we're gonna slow the
sequestration rate of those forests is
gonna continue to slow until you know we
reach kind of an equilibrium in those
areas and there's not a lot of
management that can happen in those
areas
but there are important carbon stores on
our landscape
in addition to that the state owns about
800 000 acres of state forest land
across new york
and those are actively managed forests
that are green certified
and
and their timber harvesting occurs on
those areas
but if you break that down that's not a
lot of the 18.6 million acres of forest
in new york and the rest of that is
privately owned um and so 74 of new york
forests are privately owned and if we're
gonna and so that's 69
of the carbon stocks uh on your forests
are owned by private landowners so if
you're going to make an impact in
terms of in the carbon stores and carbon
and forest space in new york you're
going to have to work with private
landowners and that's going to be a real
challenge because there's over 700 000
landowners
who own forests across new york
about 13.6 million acres of forest and
again we get this information from the
forest service and they have a national
woodland owner survey which they they
send out
every few years to to talk to woodland
owners about things that they care about
to figure out how many woodland donors
there are out and and we
use those statistics when trying to make
these kind of decisions um and so
about
close to 200 000 of those owners own 10
acres or more um which is about 68 of
the private land um and so you know i
break that statistic out just because um
ten acres
uh is an important
kind of uh reflection inflection point
for where you know you can do some
active management on those properties
where you know below 10 acres there's
there are some management actions that
can happen but really to to have a
timber harvest and to really actively
manage your properties you know we want
to focus on those forests that would
land owners who have a larger impact and
would be able to to do more sustainable
management on their properties
the concerning thing when thinking about
these landowners is that only 25 of them
of landowners surveyed in new york uh
used the forester uh professional
forester during their last harvest so
you know a lot of landowners are out
there managing their forests but aren't
um getting the
professional advice that they should be
when managing their properties um
so that's something that's going to so
private forests are really where the
take-home message here is where we're
really going to be able to make an
impact um when thinking about
increasing carbon stores across new york
and so the next thing
thinking about our our forests is what's
the structure of new york's forest so
we've talked about the the area of
forests increasing in new york over time
but um and that
is and there's a general aging of our
forests as well and so tim talked a lot
about um
the the trajectory of carbon
sequestration in the forest
um and carbon stores in a forest and if
you remember some of the things that he
talked about as as the force age is it
slows down and um you know we know that
our forests have been grown in new york
and the the data shows us that we have
an aging forest in new york so um over
the last number of years we've seen
decreases in the seedling sapling age
class forests and some of that is is
these forests regrowing we also have a
big regeneration issue in new york as
well um and
so that you know
leads to
a lot of concern over regrowth of forest
mostly due to increased deer populations
and invasive species
and so as those four stage we're going
to
they're going to slow down in terms of
carbon sequestration
the other thing to to note um when
looking at the data is that 43 of our
forests are moderately or poorly stocked
in new york and so
um
that's you know something that to take
into account that you know a lot of
those areas uh you know could have
higher stocking in those forests they're
degraded forest either through invasive
species or past management practices
and so there's going to be a lot of work
to be done within our current forest to
improve that stocking have them
fully occupy those sites
and maximize sequestration and carbon
storage within the forest there is new
york
and that's a pretty large area to be
working with
um we've also seen you know that kind of
leads into the same topic and increase
in what we in the four forestry world
call collar unacceptable growing stocks
so trees that would um not grow into a
forest product so we've seen an increase
in that in our forests over the last 10
years but that's a trend that we've been
seeing uh for a number of years so you
know that leads us to believe that
there's invasive species affecting our
forests out there um that there's past
management practices that you know have
taken the best and left the rest and as
those trees age you know they're not
going to have the economic value that
they would have um so that's going to
affect the type of management that's
going to be able to happen on those
properties and if those kind of harvests
are going to be economically viable or
if incentives um
are going to be necessary to to
encourage
and promote uh sustainable forestry on
those properties
the last thing i want to talk about
um in terms of our forest to kind of put
our uh policies into
into context here are the the tree
species in new york and tim talked a lot
about a little bit about assisted
migration um but if you look and i think
that's really an important point to hit
on
is what three species we have in our
forests new york where where those are
trending and so
red maple is a
is the most
uh common tree in new york by far
it's less commercially bought
less commercially valuable than a lot of
other trees in new york we've seen an
increase in this this tree species
in new york and a decrease in sugar
maple which is a much more valuable
species and longer-lived species
um
it's i kind of important to know as i
move through this is that eastern
hemlock and white ash are number four
and five as the most uh common trees in
new york
um
so you know we have two really big
invasive species that are affecting both
of those and that's going to be a really
big concern moving forward in terms of
the loss of those species from our
landscapes and the impact that that's
going to have on our forest as a whole
but overall we've seen relatively stable
species composition in our forests over
the last 10 years
with some gains and losses
it's one resource i just wanted to point
people out to is the usda tree atlas
and i
we can send a link around for that but
it's an interesting resource for folks
to look at projections on where tree
species
will will do well in terms of
future climate predictions so you know
if you've got some tree species that
you're looking at in your area that's
that's an interesting uh resource to
look at
all right and then
kind of the elephant in the room here is
uh
is invasive species and
um
we are affected by them
in new york especially we are affected
by them more than any other
state in the united states as you can
see by this map here we have more
invasive species
for county than than any other state in
the country and that's really due to the
you know commercial
commercial
commerce that is happening the ports
that we have
in new york city as well as um
as the
the seaway as well those
are really big entry points for
invasive species coming in on uh wood
wood packaging material like pallets
and some of the
the major invasive species that we're
seeing affecting new york um right now
asian longhorn beetles a really big
threat
but seems to be something that
has
we've had more effect um in controlling
um and recently have eradicated it from
some parts of long island that
that we had it in the past um there's
emerald ash borer which is widely
affecting ash trees across new york and
is having a really big impact on our
forest
hemlock wooly adelgid which was talked
about earlier has been in new york since
the 1980s and has been
been moving northward and has had a
really dramatic effect on
on the hemlocks in new york especially
in the hudson vat lower hudson valley in
the finger lakes region we're really
starting to see mortality in recent
years
due to hemlock willie delegate and
in the last few years we also have seen
this pest move up into the adirondacks
which at one point folks thought
might be able to resist hemlock wooly
delja due to the cold temperatures but
over time as
hwa has moved northward
it seems to have become very
weather and cold resistant it's doing
really well and that's where we have our
largest stocks of of hemlocks in new
york the most the the densest
populations of hemlocks in new york and
so that could be a real concern in the
next 20 or 30 years as hemlock will
adelgid moves up in that area
kate gets a foothold and then uh really
affects those forests in those areas
that some of them hemlock is the most
popul
common species in those in those areas
other species that we see affecting
forests the new york southern pine
beetle
has been found on long island it has
killed
thousands of acres
of pitch pine in long island
it's a species that
had never been found this far north
before it's common in the south
but due to climate change and warming
temperatures you know we're seeing it
expand its range uh into new york area
and so
that's going to be a really big concern
i know that even
in the last few years we've trapped
individuals uh much farther north than
long island um and so you know dec is
continually monitoring the pests to see
if we can to find it or in infestations
north of long island
you know the schwanngangs uh the albany
pine bush areas like that which we are
really concerned about the impact they
can have if that test takes a hold it
can
wipe out like in the south um hundreds
of acres
in a really short amount of time
spotted lanternflies and other ones that
might not be causing you know extreme
mortality um but could reduce
productivity and impact regeneration for
us so it's another test that we're
keeping an eye on
gypsy moth which
was very prevalent on our landscape last
year is also affecting affecting our
forests reducing productivity and can
cause widespread mortality at high
populations and of course touch on
disease
there's a variety of other species that
that have a large impact on our forests
and
this all compounds the problem and
speaks to kind issue that tim was
talking about in terms of permanence of
the carbon stores on those those forests
so it's important for us to to combat
those in order to
protect our forests and improve
sequestration across new york
so i won't um spend too much time on
this but this is just kind of an
overview slide and a good um
graphic in my mind on
the carbon cycle between forests
and um you know the important thing is
here is that young forest sequester
carbon faster mature forests store
carbon longer and carbon is released
from forests through things like land
use change insects and disease wildfire
and decomposition and harvests do have a
you know i would say the harvest do have
an impact on on carbon stores but
especially if those products go to
durable goods like we talked about in
the previous uh presentation
um you know that carbon forward long
term and can have a huge benefit
in terms of
continued sequestration forest
management and and climate change
so
just to kind of bring this back to a
policy lens now that we've put it into
context and where our new york forests
are currently
we're looking at the graph on the left
here talks about our sequestration goals
and the current sequestration rate in
new york forest
so how many million metric tons per year
our forests are sequestering and in
about 1990 so 30 years ago or so we were
storing about 30 million metric tons of
carbon um we've seen that rate decrease
as our forest has aged been affected by
invasive species
to you know about 25
million metric tons today 26 somewhere
around there and we again we get this
data from
the forest service uh inventory analysis
project as well as i'm using some land
cover
uh data as well to look at
using satellite imagery to see where
forests are and make some calculations
there and so looking forward we're
hoping to try to reverse that trend by
2030 through our strategies um in terms
of keeping forests as forests and
improving forest management a4 station
reforestation
adding trees to our urban landscapes and
then
using good forest management and
bioeconomy
to
to sequester carbon and we're going to
need to
if we were to um offset 15
of of emissions by 2050 we're going to
need to sequester about or have our
forest sequester about 60 million metric
tons so over double what
they're sequestering today so that's a
tall order uh for our forest
but you know i think
we have some really aggressive
tactics that we're looking to move
forward and you know we're going to to
see how far we can get on to reaching
that goal
so uh
first strategy that i want to talk a
little bit about is keeping foresters
for us
and on the right here we see the current
carbon stores in new york and this is
the info information put out by fia but
we are also working with
esf
utilizing some satellite imagery
lidar data to try to refine this
um and so we will hopefully in the
coming years have some
uh
more precise tools coming on to tell us
where we're gaining carbon where we're
losing carbon to target some of our work
and so that's really important work
that's going on
but if you look at this area you see
that our highest carbon stores
unsurprisingly are in the adirondacks in
the catskill park
areas the tug hill also has quite a bit
of carbon stored
but you see a lot of opportunity in the
finger lakes region the north country
and
and areas in in the in there um the
hudson valley also seems to have a lot
less carbon stores
definitely probably related to the
um
to
things like development and things like
that in that area
so our strategies um for keeping forces
for us obviously one of the main things
here would be land acquisition so fee
and conservation easements are a really
important part of that so fee ownership
would be purchasing the property
outright
in conservation easements
let the land keep the land owned in
private hands but
usually it's the purchasing of
development rights of that property so
it keeps those forests as forests
while allowing for
them to be working lands especially when
talking about the adirondack park
the this strategy would relate to state
acquisitions municipal acquisitions land
trust acquisitions but you know taking
that development pressure away from
those properties
i we think that you know local
governments are going to be a key part
of this and including
acquisition of really important
properties to them
and their communities in their
comprehensive plans and two new programs
that we've been rolling out at dec this
year are a community forest grant
program which
uh funds
municipalities to purchase community
forests um land that might not fit you
know a state profile for what a state
would purchase but
and keeps the hands the forests and
local control
as well as a conservation easement for
land trust program
which is going to help fund
some land trust purchasing more
properties across new york
the next strategy here is um real
property tax incentives for forest land
owners and this strategy really fits
into both
uh improved forest management as well as
keeping forces for us so i'm going to
kind of talk about it here
but i think it's important to note that
properties that are managed under
the current 4ada forest tax law program
are harvest more sustainably than
properties that are not and some studies
have shown that in new york especially
in the watershed the new york city
watershed region as well as better man
bmps occur on those properties as well
but there are definitely incentives tied
to
to a lot of those practices which
encourage good management
and so
our 488 forest tax law program is a
program that's been around since the
1970s it what came together after
an older program 480
and it's a timber focus program so it's
managing properties for the for
sustainable timber products coming off
that property
parcels have to be at least 50 acres
of forests
and there's penalties in terms of
taking your property out of 48 and so
since this program is older it's not
carbon focused it is really um
a timber production focus we think that
it needs some updates um legislatively
to be amended
and that's something that you know the
is the recommendation that came from the
forestry panel with the clcpa um
and
uh to modernize the program uh reduce
that acre threshold possibly to allow
more lenders to take uh ben you know
take advantage of the program currently
only nine percent of um eligible
landowners in new york are are part of
this um but if you try to get out of 4da
they're also very strict penalties so
that's how it really helps people keep
their properties by reducing the burden
of taxes on them is an 80
reduction in the assessed value of those
properties
but also
uh because those properties will be
benefiting the public and uh creating a
sustained forest product off of them
they're required to have management
plans be managed by a professional
forester and those plans are reviewed by
dec staff
in addition to that program i think the
state has recognized the importance that
not everyone wants to manage their
properties for timber and that's also
that has a real benefit and so 480b and
480c are two newer programs that uh were
recommended out of the 4c panel that
have smaller acreage requirements for
landowners
and you know timber harvesting is not a
requirement of that property but if done
would have to be done by a professional
forester and and go through the dec
approval process
and so that you know ensures that
sustainable practices are happening on
the property
but also gives people a tax benefit for
holding forest land in new york um
while reducing the tax burden on those
properties um to help people you know
keep those properties um in forests and
keep them
from getting partialized and fragmented
we've seen
over the last number of years
a reduction in the average size of
forest land holdings in new york as
properties get continually split up
which limits the potential for those
properties to be managed sustainably
and
increases development on those
properties
and so you know there's some specifics
here in terms of
how those programs would work and i'd be
glad to talk about it more with folks
but you know they are are relatively
general recommendations but we see a
need to
give the landowners more options to get
more landowners enrolled in these type
of programs so these programs have a
broader impact
all the states around new york currently
have tax law programs
they all are similar but also very
different and you know programs like
vermont's use value appraisal program
have
much higher enrollment and you see you
know 60 70 of the four eligible forests
in that those areas
enrolled in those programs so it has
those programs tend to have a broader
scope
they affect more landowners and and can
really
push the
you know good management out onto the
landscape
and the last
strategy here is regulating forest land
conversion
and as
we talk about the importance of carbon
stores and combating carbon
and combating climate change and carbon
sequestration we recognize the
importance of forests uh for all new
yorkers for the value that those forests
provide and similar to um you know
wetland protection laws which saw the
importance of wetlands um
you know this
would this regulation or keeping forces
forest law um would try to prevent
land um
land conversion uh and so
the law would be set up similar to
what a um
what our wetland law would be which
would look to avoid impacts the forest
to minimize where possible and then to
mitigate those carbon losses
um
one of the recommendations before she
panel
talked about was exempting agriculture
from from this as land kind of fluxes
between those two
areas regularly and
agricultural lands would be
still working land
and the soil would still be intact in
those areas so that was an important
distinction that the panel recommended
participating in carbon markets is a
pretty complicated thing and i can talk
about it more as well but um you know
these are ways carbon markets are
uh growing in popularity we see you know
a number of folks starting to get
involved in them especially if they have
larger land holdings of 2 000 or more
acres
but they do promote good forest
management on those properties through
long-term contracts that are typically
signed by most of these and it's
something that the clc the
that they need to be explored more
to see how we can
and
incentivize good management on the
properties
um
in terms of we do not have a mandatory
market in new york and that's something
that that hasn't been set up yet um as
the clcta puts quite a bit of
um
strict regulations on
those on how that would be set up in
terms of offsets needing to be within 25
miles i think it is of
of an emission source so
that would make it quite challenging to
put something like that together
because a lot of the mission sources you
know don't have available uh mitigation
areas close to
um
to those source areas
all right so the next strategy that i
want to talk about here is improved
forest management so
the importance of um
of increasing the carbon stocks in our
current forests
and uh the i talked about a little bit
earlier but forest pests play a huge
role in your forest
and and the carbon stocks there we've
seen
emerald ash borer especially and hemlock
willie aldridge having
impact on our forest
across new york
as we we lose those species
from the landscape
and so these forest pests can reduce
productivity increase mortality on the
landscape and there's an increased need
for prevention rapid response i'm going
to talk a little bit about later about
some resources that folks can
can
get to
with that and dec has a bureau of
invasive species management that that
can help folks with management of their
forests and combat invasive species
the next
is improved silviculture and restoration
of degraded stands and
you know i think it's important that we
facilitate good management on our
properties and reduce and eliminate high
grading
in those forests so we don't have those
degraded stands and under stock stands
um taking the best and leaving the rest
is a practice that
has been documented in new york it
reduces genetic
quality of trees in the area and the
capacity of those forced to recover and
tim talked a little bit about how to
deal with those stands unfortunately we
don't have very good low-grade markets
to deal with a lot of these degraded
stands so
we're going to need real incentives to
help landowners have the tools they need
to restore these stands
obviously outreach to landowners
carb specific carbon training for
foresters and incentives to to help
landowners
restore impacted stands
one of the big issues in new york and
the
the map here on the right talks about
regeneration issues in new york and dr
and over browsing by deer are is a huge
issue in new york in terms of forestry
the important thing to look at with this
map is anything that's red orange or
yellow is considered insecure areas in
terms of regeneration so if you lose a
force in that area due to
invasive species a wind disturbance
or a harvest
those are areas that you cannot
guarantee that you're going to get that
forest coming back
naturally or very quickly and so you
could have continuation of some like
shrublands which have a limited
potential for sequestration and
regeneration
there are a few areas in new york that
have secure generation regeneration but
those areas are few and far between
this work was done by tnc and
you know i can provide some some of
those links for folks if they're
interested
a really big strategy here is terms of a
forestation reforestation so combating
the loss of forests we're really going
to need to plant new trees um in areas
identify and prioritize areas that need
new trees and um
and try to
to reforest our our our landscape
so
the work the map here on the right is
work done by tnc again
on the reforestation hub
there's some really interesting work
here on availability of land for
reforestation
i think it's kind of important to if you
think back to our carbon stock snap that
we were putting up is that
the areas that have the lowest carbon
stock seem to have the most area
available for reforestation so the
adirondacks and the catskills don't have
a lot of area that we're going to be
able to reforest but you know your
finger lakes region um your north
country are areas where we can really
make an impact this strategy
um tnc
estimated close to four million acres
might be available for reforestation i
think actual um acreage is going to be a
bit lower than that and you know maybe
in the 1 million to 2 million range in
terms of you know what people are
willing and want forests on their
property
what areas
are being used for pasture and for
agricultural purposes so where we're
going to be able to put that those trees
and i think there's also an important
crossroads here
in terms of the conflict with renewable
energy so a lot of the areas that are
good locations for solar siting are also
good locations for planting so you know
there's going to be a need to prioritize
both of those actions and so um
and so we're gonna have to put solar out
in the landscape we're gonna have to put
forests on the landscape and
um gonna need to make sure that those
two are not in conflict with each other
and we're doing both of them
simultaneously
the other thing that we're going to work
on is reforesting our under stock stands
and so that's going to be a really
important part of this process as well
i'm just going to talk really briefly
about urban forestry urban forestry is
a really important part of our carbon
stocks than that it um those trees in
urban settings sequester carbon
they also
reduce energy costs
and of our homes
and so they they have that
multiple effect
in terms of climate change and so
increasing uh tree canopies in our urban
areas is going to be really important
the dec currently has grant programs for
communities that we put out regularly in
this space and you know we're going to
need to really
ramp those programs up if we're going to
make an impact in that area
we have you know generally seen a
decrease in our urban forest over the
the last number of years um and you know
i can just tell you from my community as
we have increased wind storms um we i
see trees come down um then i hear
chainsaws going as everyone starts
taking some more trees down and very
rarely do i see folks replant big trees
um sometimes i'll see small trees but
you know i see very few big trees being
replanted in our communities and that's
something that you know we're going to
need to work on reversing that trend
and bioeconomy is also really important
so this
use of durable wood products
supporting our forest industry and the
creation of those can be essential if
we're going to you know continue having
good management on our landscape
um also you know these lumber products
are sequestering or you know have
sequestered carbon um while the you know
substitute products they have like
concrete or steel you know uh take quite
a bit of carbon to create and so you
know there's a real a lot to be gained
by using these products and there are
definitely a lot of hurdles in terms of
the construction industry
what they are used to using standard
practices and getting these practices
out in the landscape i think mass timber
it has a real potential to make a big
impact if we can
get more adoption from
developers when making properties when
making buildings
so the last section of my talk today i
just want to talk about some
opportunities that landowners have a lot
of these
programs have been running long-standing
programs but we have some new programs
at dec
that can help landowners
manage their properties
you know there's a lot of things that
we've recommended in the clcpa to help
improve
forest management on the landscape
and a lot of those haven't been
implemented yet so there's a lot to be
gained
you know a lot of things that hopefully
will be coming down the line um but this
is you know kind of what's available
right now and so i'm going to run
through a couple dec programs and touch
briefly on
the natural resource conservation
services program which is uh
the environmental quality incentives
program equip it's it's quite a long
name but um
you know that has is a long-standing
program um that
you know helps people do improved force
management on the property so
um equip has a forced stand improvement
practice
which helps people you know improve the
sustained forced health and productivity
and one of the newer
practices that they're allowing here is
increase or maintain carbon storage
in their forests is another
practice and so
you need to talk with a professional
forester if you want to get involved in
these programs or your local nrcs office
this is a grant program and i i
apologize i'm not sure when they they
open up their program but um
it's
it's also cost share so i think
landowners do have to
do some contributing to this kind of a
program
our dc's for stewardship program is
long-standing it connects to landowners
across the landscape with professional
forestry advice
and management advice dec land or forest
staff will go out and walk the land with
the landowner and work on
either putting together a paper
management plan for them or giving them
some technical assistance and basic
guidance
based on availability of our staff
unfortunately in reduction in the amount
of staff that we have to do this
you know we don't do a full inventory
and stuff that a consulting forester
would do and so after you know
connecting with the land owner and
finding out what their goals for
management are and what they're looking
to do we often refer them to a
cooperating forester private consultant
who works on a fee basis with them
for a lot of what they want to do if
you're looking to do a timber harvest we
always recommend working with a
consulting forester
to get the best outcome that you're
looking for on that harvest
our 4da program as i talked about a
little bit earlier needs to be
updated but it is still a really
beneficial program
it provides an 80 reduction in the
assessed that value of forest land that
someone owns that's committed to this
program it's a rolling 10-year
commitment and so every year that you
get the benefit you are
enrolled for another 10 years out from
that and has put the lien on the deed
and so it really is sort of like a con
temporary conservation easement on those
properties
but it also you know connects those
landowners with the tools that they need
to properly manage their properties
through professional forester force
and
and dec oversight in terms of reviewing
those management plans and prescriptions
for those harvests
but the big crux here is that landowners
have to have at least 50 acres to commit
and you know there are a lot of
requirements of the program so it's
really important that landowners know
what they're getting into when they sign
up for this kind of a program
but you know only nine percent of new
york forests are enrolled in this um
so it's
really a small percentage of new york
forests and so we need to really expand
this in order to
make a big impact out on the landscape
just a few other programs we run our
trees for trips programs buffer in a bag
through the saratoga tree nursery
provides
trees for land
for landowners who are looking to
reforest
reforest riparian areas our saratoga
tree nursery does sealing sales each
year and sells
pretty cheap ceilings to folks across
new york
and our urban forestry grant program is
available to municipalities and um and
non-profits
uh to either get urban management plans
do tree planting um
work and and things like that so really
is working in that space and i think
that the newest
round of that grant is going to be
released sometime in 2022.
and then i just want to talk briefly
about our newest program that where we
started we just finished our first round
in new york which is regenerate new york
which is really you know targeting some
of this climate work
and
um
we had a few out four eligible practices
here a4 station reforestation stand
restoration competing controlling
competing vegetation and deer enclosures
and this is a
um
the round one had about 450 000 dollars
that we allocated to landowners between
that at least three thousand to fifty
thousand dollars um
in money for that there was a 25 percent
match for landowners so they had to
match some of the work that was
happening out there but it you know
helps get some some of this work out in
the landscape and get it started you
know unfortunately when thinking about
the impact of this program that 450 000
got us about 500 acres of impacted sites
so we're going to
if we want to reforest a million acres
you know this might not be the easiest
way to do it is getting a lot of that
work done we're going to really need to
ramp up what we're doing
and then i
really briefly talked about invasive
species i mentioned we have a bureau of
invasive species and ecosystem health in
dec
and
we've got folks out there surveying for
invasive species we do really rely on
citizen scientists and i just wanted to
mention here imap invasives is a great
resource for folks if you don't know
about it it's a way to report invasive
species that you see
all your submissions will be reviewed so
if you're not sure what it is you can
still put it in and a dec staff member
is going to look at it and confirm or
deny
what you see out there and so that's a
great resource for folks to connect them
with some technical experts
our forest health email is also a way to
email pictures and questions and
there are local
partnerships for regional invasive
species management or prisms
that are grassroots networks for
managing invasive species across new
york that dec funds
and our local experts at some of the
invasive species in your area so if
you've got invasive species questions
there are a lot of resources out there
for you
and
dec is here to help as well as our
partners
that is all that i had today
that was fantastic brian thank you so
much
peter will field some questions and i
will set out a poll
yes thanks very much brian and and
thanks back to tim also for a lot of
great information
we have a question
uh
please discuss how the clcpa limits
offset possibilities
yeah so i mentioned this briefly and i'm
not an expert in the offset
field but in terms of
i know that the clcpa in terms of its
mandatory if you were to set up a
mandatory market where folks are able to
offset
um it limits the distance that those
offsets could be
placed from
um
from where that emission source is
and so
you know that's a
important part of it i think also it's
important to note that in terms of you
know statewide sequestration and carbon
neutrality goal by 2050
we're not looking at offsets it's more
the total sequestration
rate for new york forest
and so that's an important distinction
there
great thanks
another question
has the department of lands and forests
consulted with the department of ag and
markets on goals for aforestation
or reforestation of agricultural areas
are there a specific strategies
so this is a great um outcome from the
uh 4g panel as it was um
it was working directly with ag markets
on this and so you know we we've
collaborated quite a bit in terms of
that we haven't we're still working on
creating prioritization of areas um but
you know and i think some of the work
that's been done by
private groups on tnc for example you
know trying to identify those marginal
lands that are not currently in
agricultural production that would be um
ideal for creating forests and we have
definitely worked with
um worked with agon markets and and will
continue to especially with their soil
and water conservation districts with uh
which are um
really have a lot of on the ground
knowledge on in this area
great thanks so much
uh here's another question what is the
status of 480b and 480c
are they enacted where can we get more
information
um so those were recommended by the
forestry panel 480b and 4dc they are not
enacted they
um
i will say here in terms of um the clcpa
and you know our climate work is that
the scoping plan which i mentioned
earlier is
being developed and will be released for
public comment in
2022
so in january of 2022 in just a few days
and so the recommendations um that came
out of the forest panels work
are in there
those are two recommendations that were
created in there
they are not enacted they are just
currently recommendations the the plan
will be available for public comment all
of next year um and you know we look for
the legislature to be to move on those
if it's something that they prioritize
thanks and here's
another question about the clcpa
does the clcpa or any current proposed
legislation take deer management and
deer impact on forest regeneration into
account
um in the recommendations we do talk
about fear management and regeneration
issues
um
though
you know i would say that um
it is is not a prime focus i think some
of the work that we've done to
regenerate new york um
talks about more about excluding beer
from regeneration areas through fencing
practices and things like that um
and and does not directly talk about
reducing populations of herds across new
york state
okay
another question since new york state
does not have a licensure program for
foresters how will the state bring in
loggers or other folks that do not have
training into plans to improve silver
culture for carbon sequestration
that's an important point
that we don't have a licensing program
for forest foresters across new york
what we do have is the long-standing
cooperating forester program at dec so
folks that
are on that list are our folks that
cooperate with dec they have a set of
wrecks of requirements in terms of
education to have that and we're working
on um
getting training directly to those
members as well as you know
the the forestry professionals in
general in this area um you know that's
something that
some local recent grants have to have
started and we're hoping to roll out in
the next few years
so here's a question i think you've
partially answered this but clearly it's
on people's minds is there an
anticipated timeline for implementation
of legislative opportunities for
landowners under the clcpa
so the
in terms of the plan the plan the
scoping plan will be
you know out for public comment
all
you know for a period of time next year
um i'm not sure exactly at the timeline
that that's going to be out i think it
will be you know 120 160 day comment
period
and the
plan is to finalize that by 2023
and so then you know we would hope that
the implementation of those
recommendations would come soon after
that
um you know i think dec has a lot of
programs in this area which i
highlighted as well and you know we're
already you know moving forward and
trying to integrate carbon management
into those programs as quickly as
possible so what we're able to do
without legislative approval um we're
moving forward with within our dec
programs currently
well thanks brian
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu